i will now ask the government officer to
read out the domestic arrangements and
the fire regulations clear over to you
thank you chair
please ensure that your main social
social distancing from all other persons
whilst in the chamber and in the
communal areas please ensure that you
wear a face covering at all times unless
you are sitting down or if you exempt
from doing so and that you use the hand
sanitizer and wipes provided
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking
if you're attending the meeting to speak
and persistently entering the meeting
you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off
we will not be using e-voting for this
meeting as we have issues this morning
with mod gov so voting will be by a show
of hands
if you hear the fire alarm leave the
building immediately by a fire exit and
make your way to the assembly point
follow the signs directing you to the
fire exits at each end of the floor do
not enter the atrium if you're in the
atrium at the time of the alarm follow
the signs to the nearest fire exit
use the stairs not the lifts and do not
re-enter the building until it's told
safe to do so
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
thank you chair thank you do we have to
do a roll call because we're not using
the
gov
is present we do don't we
okay that's fine
thank you john for that help
okay moving on introductions the area
planning management today is mark
russell
ian duprey is our legal advisor who's
already jumped into action
case officers with flood
and the government's obviously clear you
already know
we have no ward members
no okay no ward member presence
apologies for absence and substitutions
thank you chair we have apologies from
councillor parker and councillor busby
and councillor horan is substituting for
councillor busby thank you thank you
are there any declarations of interest
no
confirmation of the minutes in the last
meeting
are there any points
because the accuracy of these minutes
no in that case could i have a proposer
it comes with a beer
do i have a seconder
council osborne
can we just have a
show of hands
to approve
it's nine plus one nine one abstention
yes
um chairman i'm a pint of the minutes um
are we getting
minutes for the
january meeting
no because that was only an informal
meeting so there will be no minutes so
we don't have any record of what went on
there's an internal record there is a we
have
made a note of what happened at that
meeting but it won't be
distributed is this available for
councillors to see
i can go i can i can
send them out to if you want to see them
well you know an informal meeting that
we were present there yep um
i i think members should at least see
copy of it
yes i can yeah i can send them around
thank you thank you very much all right
thank you
thank you everyone
notifications and petitions
any requests for site inspections okay
okay
right moving on schedule planning
applications
23 bridge street hadley
elizabeth over to you
thank you chair so this is 23 bridge
street in hadley and it's for minor
alterations to the previously approved
listed building consent
this is the
site here so it's this building on the
corner
with the malt house
here and 21 bridge street in this
location
again you can see it on the plan
and
here you can see the constraints so the
key one here is that it's grade two
listed as is the adjoining building
and then the grade two grade two star
21 bridge street is in that location
again these are the existing elevations
as and the office
the proposed elevation so there's
there's no change in the elevations and
again the previously approved uh
elevations again there's no change in
the elevations from what's previously
been approved
these show the fabric to be removed so
there's some internal fabric
from the offices to be removed
and this is the existing
um plan as as the officers as they are
now
this is the proposed and
the key changes in this
is um
the internal layout so that where what
what rooms are being used for what
purposes are changing slightly and
that's allowing for the additional
bedroom
at the top flat so this bedroom is new
and there's some changes in this
location to allow for a couple of
bathrooms
and so yeah as you can see on here so
this was was the bathroom and this would
be the bedroom and then the various
rooms uh various functions of the rooms
are changing
again this is the other alteration
there's going to be a new set of timber
gates between 21 and 23.
and this is the
existing so this is 23 here
21's in this location
these will be the new gates in this
location here
um and you can see that there won't be
any elevational changes and then these
are the the malt house in this location
again this is looking at it from going
up the other way
so this is 23 in this location and then
the gates and then
21
and the recommendation is as in your
report so approval with conditions
no okay
there's no public speakers we have no
agents
uh i'll now open up the item for debate
in that case anybody wants to start a
comment
or a proposal or a
thank you chairman um yes we're talking
about some fairly minor uh alterations
here
uh
just
it says in the recommendation details of
repairs
but we're getting an awful lot of these
sort of um
let's hand it over to officers and
they'll sort it all out but
it'd be nice to know what sort of
repairs they're talking about there and
are they for instance talking about
repairs to the brickwork on the frontage
of the building because at the bottom of
it it's sort of gradually falling to
pieces isn't it as water damage as uh
eroding the brickwork
yes so we will be looking at all the
repairs that needs to be done to the to
the internal and external fabric that
will be retained and we were asking for
details of those because of the listed
status of the building
and you make a decision on those or
other planning department make a
decision on those or would it come back
before members
that's delegated to offices councillor
uh in liaison with our heritage experts
obviously it's minor matters about how
things are patched up make sure we use
the right sort of more to that sort of
thing
thank you
any more comments
control
could i suggest that we accept the
officer's
proposal because thank you
i'm happy to second that this is fairly
uncontroversial and straightforward okay
any more comments if not
we'll take a vote
all those in five of the office
recommendation please show
thank you chair that's unanimous
thank you very much
moving on
number 21 bridge street an adjoining
building
elizabeth
so
again this is another application for
minor minor internal alterations to the
previously approved listed building
consent
the 21
bridge street
you can see
it's in this location
so it's the building on the corner
again you can see it there as part of
the council offices
structures
it's this location here constraints as
you can see this is grade two star
so it's the most important of all the
great
all the listed buildings within the
council complex
again you can see it there so what is
proposed to be demolished is just a
single story uh 1980s rear extension
just this tiny bit here which links it
to the
um
this building
again these are the existing
elevations
these are the proposed so the key
changes are in this location here
uh where there's going to be some bifold
doors and so on
um
and these are the previously approved
elevations again there's no change in
the elevations
these are the existing floor plans as
the offices
and these are the proposed floor plans
the key changes on this one
are
the ground floor is
uh reduced from
two bedrooms the ground floor flat is
reduced from three bedrooms to two
bedrooms with the introduction of these
bathrooms here
and
there's an additional
wc in this location and an ensuite in
this location
so if i show you the approved plans
you can see originally they were
proposing two
bedrooms here so it was a three bedroom
flat
and then um
here there was no wc and there was no
ensuite here so it's just minor changes
again
again the existing the proposed gates
between 23 and 21
and this is the photograph so that's the
building
you can just see it there with the
little addition it is there and then the
gates
and the recommendation is as set out in
your report for approval with conditions
any questions for the officer
no we have no
public speakers again
um
therefore i will
open it up for debate
and if there's no debate can i ask for a
proposal in a second
i've got a question mr chairman or
debate whatever you'll take it um
do we know when they're likely to be
starting on any of this um i i know
this what we're discussing here is a
little bit separate but uh it's been
ongoing for some time is there a end
date a start date in the offering thank
you
my understanding is that they are keen
to start there are going to be
pre-commencement conditions that will
need discharging prior to any start so
that it's being worked on and once those
are discharged then they will be
starting but i don't have an exact date
unless mark does we have the um
applicant part of the council here if
you and with them that's not very
helpful i accept what you're saying it's
not your fault we're clean to start it
could be clean next year couldn't it so
if you can get an answer that would
we do have
a me attack here would you like to
comment
if you can
okay
thank you very much
i mean
again it's minor but in heritage terms
it actually represents an improvement on
the existing situation so i propose
propose that we accept the officer's
recommendation thank you
lee
and us our second councilman
thank you match cameron sir jameson
um do we need to read that we don't
deserve to freshen our memories fine i
will ask us all to
players carry out the vote for me
yeah so can we have a show of hands
please counsellors thank you
thank you that's unanimous
thank you very much
moving on
we're still in bridge street but at the
malt house in adjoining buildings
elizabeth
uh
okay
so this is for
minor amendments to previously approved
uh listed building content application
at the malt house and adjoining
buildings
so
this is the set of buildings
here so this is the listed one and then
the previous council chamber and the
various
structures around
it again that's the site location plan
you can see which bit is listed so it's
just a little bit here
and then just along there as
well um these are the proposed
elevations
uh so the key changes are in this
externally at this location here
where the existing external stairs are
this is going to be an introduction of a
balcony and some timber gates at the
bottom
in addition these um
windows will all be
become tough and safety glass to protect
them from any
cricket balls that might come this way
again you could just see on the approved
this was going to be sort of timber
cladding because this was going to be
the staircase and that's changed i'll
show you that on the internal plans
again these are the the windows to be to
have been replaced with toughened glass
they'll remain in the same style but
just better glass
okay these are the existing elevations
so again at the moment this is the stair
tower with the metal external fire
escape staircase
okay and there are internal
changes as well so
this is existing as the offices and the
council chamber
these are the proposed
so
there are
some changes
in this location where the front door
would be so just some extra cupboarding
then in
this location the stairs were going to
be at the back here
and they've been changed to here and
then there are some minor changes to uh
the wind sort of wall positions within
the wider building
again so you can see on the previously
approved
elevation
sorry floor plan the stairs were in this
location
um and now they're proposed to be at the
at the front
and if we just go
back you can see where they were going
to go
is now sort of storage area and then a
balcony at the front at the top
so that's the main elevational change
again you can see the demolition so that
the main build the more modern buildings
to be demolished
and the removal of the fabric
these are the gates
oh and in question these are the ones at
the back where the existing staircases
and then the balcony would be above
and you could just see it so
this is the listed part of the building
and then it's just this elevation this
little link here
again you can just about see it there
that's the external metal stair gate and
that's where there will be some changes
and again the recommendation is set out
in your report for approval with
conditions
thank you elizabeth any questions for
the officer
her
housemate
thank you chair um
elizabeth i wasn't on the committee when
this first was approved but i've just
got a general question
given the heritage implications of this
site
does that impact on
the people who may purchase the
accommodation in the future other
restrictions that they have to follow in
relation to the site thank you
the buildings will remain listed so if
they wanted to do
certain internal changes or external
changes then they would require
um listed building consent so there will
be that impact i don't know they're if
they're flat they're likely to be
leasehold anyway so there would be you
know an overall management company who
would put in for any external changes
presumably but that would be the main
change
thank you thank you
thank you mr chairman uh yeah the
decision on the the netting the going
can you could the officer show us
exactly how far that
netting that they're going to put in
goes round how high it would be
and also
it's the old story if the ball goes
beyond that fence can they get in and
get it
thank you
i haven't got the plans for the netting
because that was actually previously
approved on the previous
uh application
um from memory
it's sort of goes along the back of it
and it's tall i don't know if mark's got
some more
information from
i haven't got much more than that thank
you um it does the job it's supposed to
as per the resolution for pity committee
back in 2019 to protect the windows
basically and was agreed with
the england wells cricket board and
hadley cricket club
that's all i have for you on that sorry
so why has it taken so long to get that
approval then
it was
a tricky business getting the right
specification of net which did what it's
supposed to do
um eventually it was sorted out i think
it was late 2020 it was finally sorted
out
if i can mr chairman
you say the
from
liz's comments that it will go along by
the building but i i understood it it
would actually cover the the car park
area that netting all the way through up
as far as the school box actually
i can try and find that information if
you want um council but share that
that's
it's not for today uh not for this lb
application but i can get you that
information you want to cancel
afterwards
you should keep the ball on the ground
not in the air when you're playing
possible
council beer
thank you mr chairman that was really a
similar question to councillor osborne
and being a crooked empire he he knows
what he's talking about on this this has
been
something that's caused us a problem
this fencing does slide 16 show that
fencing um and i would like to know how
high that is and the length that goes
along like cancel i was born i know it's
not you're talking about the netting or
the the the netting the netting yeah
because i think in that case i i think
you you if you'll ask you'll speak to
the area manager afterwards and ask for
that information because that's
not part of this application at this
particular time so that's already been
agreed that's already been agreed
right
well then why has this taken so long
then mr chairman because i thought this
was where all the problems was like um
pencil osbourne uh that this cricket uh
had held up the progress of this
development side i think um
manager
just told councillor osborne that it was
the netting getting the right time of
netting to do the job that was the
problem mark would you like to expand on
that yes that was the uh initial reason
for the delay uh council appear before
the decision notice itself went out
which as i say from memory was sometime
like 2020 i could have that wrong
and the
subsequent delay has been that once the
developer side of the council started
works or they looked started works they
realized that some of the rooms didn't
work properly so they've come back with
some changes
so that that's what's happened
from 2021 to now
[Music]
it's an on-running process after six and
a half years i'm still getting my name
wrong um just wanted to point out well
just to clarify as far as i can see we
have a situation where we have both
netting and toughened safety glass to
protect the residents now that's an
improvement isn't it on the previous
arrangements
thank you
all of those matters were
part of the resolution back in 2019
which had to be sorted out before
decision notice was issued i can't now
remember about the toughened glass to be
honest with you but certainly
certainly the net took a little bit my
point is that this application contains
reference to the toughened safety glass
and that seems to be an improvement am i
correct in that assessment
yeah i
i believe it was on the planning
application but not the previous listed
building consent
okay thank you
thank you mr chair i'd just like to
agree a lot with
councillor beer however
my uh
position with this was that the hold up
was due to the maintenance of that
netting in other words the cricket club
didn't want to pay for the maintenance
of that net in every so many years
to be replaced so can i just ask whether
whether the uh developer has actually
agreed that they would do that
once it'll just go on again
i now can't remember because it was it's
all sorted out the end of 2020. all of
these questions i can answer for you
later on council responder council
appear but i don't have the information
immediately here that's not the subject
of this application it's the minor
changes which you've just seen described
by mr flood
the end of the day that was one of the
reasons for the hold up
and it went on for far too long in my
opinion so why hadn't that got sorted
out
thank you
the basis of the application before us
however and i agree that there are
issues from the past but i don't see any
point in rehashing those i'd like to
propose the motion as recommended by
officers thank you can we have a second
council mclaren
do you have a vote
do all those in favor please show
thank you chair
and that's the end of our
deliberations this morning i will now
formally close the meeting
you